so long as they stay in power joining me
now Molly Hemingway editor-in-chief of
the Federalist and Charlie hurt
Washington Times opinion editor both are
Fox News contributors Molly there's a
lot of news to get through but they they
really are ramping up this rhetoric I
mean we actually have good data points
on what's going to happen to energy and
our personal freedoms if Biden gets four
more years because of what he's saying
um but they are saying democracy itself
will end yeah they're saying democracy
itself will end unless they are able to
prevent Americans from voting for the
candidate of their choice which is a
democratic principle but they are they
are willing to do anything and the
Atlantic is willing to do anything
during the first Trump presidency they
lied about Russia collusion they
participated in the Kavanaugh rape smear
they felt that these things were
Justified because of their hatred for
Republican voters and the candidates
they vote for Charlie if democracy is
truly on the line again as these people
all suck up to China and they suck up to
all these other despotic regimes but if
democracy is really on the line
gosh you pretty much have to do anything
to save democracy it sounds almost like
a you know egging people on to conflict
yeah no I I think that's a really
important Point uh Laura that that uh
has to be made here you know that is
exactly why they're using this very
extreme language because we are now at
the point as Molly points out you know
they are so terrified of actual
democracy that they're willing to put
somebody in jail or take him off the
ballot so that people cannot vote for
the person that they want to vote for
and the only way you can justify doing
that is if you call it some massive uh
emergency that is an existential threat
to the country and an existential threat
to democracy as we know it which is why
and of course they have to talk about
that because they can't talk about any
of the issues because on the issues ever
you cannot point to a single issue on
which uh Democrats have the upper hand
over conservatives or republican now and
Molly speaking of this idea of egging
people into conflict zelenski today
comes to the um right a whole Entourage
for them and it seemed like he was
trying to bait people into you know more
uh action
um and he took a step further watch
if Ukraine Falls Putin will surely go
further what will the United States of
America do when Putin reaches the Baltic
states when he reaches the Polish border
he will if the Russians reach Poland
what's next a third world war
Molly well this is a really big issue
for us right now a lot of American
voters they do not believe that there
should be endless spending on the war in
Ukraine particularly as Ukraine's own
Neighbors in Europe are not spending
nearly as much as we are not you know
just just a tiny fraction of what we are
on this war Americans won wars fought in
our national interest they want things
brought to Peaceful ends they want to
deal with the reality of the situation
and the reality includes that we have a
tremendous amount of debt in our country
and we have a lot of things that we need
to care about that we should be focused
on as well so it is interesting it'll be
interesting to see how zelenski's visit
goes this time around versus the
previous yeah that was on 60 Minutes
obviously then Charlie you you hear
Biden and the Biden cabinet when they
talk about Ukraine I've never seen them
more passionate about anything except
maybe climate change but they're so
passionate about Ukraine I mean they
will pretty much do anything for
zelenski much more than they would ever
do to engage with conservative
Republicans on the hill
and I think that strikes people as as
odd when obviously he's happy to have
our own border totally overrun with what
seven and a half million people exactly
and Counting
yeah and and of course sadly uh there
are also some Republicans in that camp
as well who get very very spun up at the
notion of spending more taxpayer dollars
in Ukraine uh but of course this is the
Biden administration's War uh the entire
war occurred because of Joe Biden's uh
Reckless uh disregard for American
Energy Independence which jacked the
price of fuel up and uh gave uh Vladimir
Putin the money to invade a country that
he never should have invaded uh but so
so obviously Democrats are are you know
the the number one cheerleaders for this
and as you point out uh they show they
really show their hand you know Joe
Biden's in New York City today and
refused to even meet with a Democratic
mayor Eric Adams who is struggling under
the catastrophe of illegal immigration
caused entirely by Joe Biden and his
refusal to or his willingness to throw
open the gates at the border to invite
in millions of new illegals
well and Molly I think Charlie's point
about the Republicans in the Senate if
it weren't for those votes of of those
what 14 or so Republicans in the senate
for this this funding
a continued funding extreme funding of
Ukraine this really wouldn't be
happening I mean it would force the
Democrats hand in the house who were
kind of free to do whatever they want
now right and Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell has said that funding
Ukraine is the Republican party's
foremost desire it's insane it is it's a
it's not true it's not true at all it's
not true of American voters in general
it's particularly not true of Republican
voters and it speaks to this problem
that we're having that there's a general
lack of leadership in the Senate it's
true that they're the minority party but
Democrats when they're the minority
party are actually able to get quite a
bit done yeah Mitch McConnell has been
unable to advance the Republican agenda
he's been unable to advance or
articulate what that is it's causing
problems for people in the house as well
the house is trying to work on these on
a spending Bill and they have gotten no
support from the Senate who just want to
spend there there's no difference in
what
um Senate uh what Mitch McConnell wants
to spend and what
makes it very difficult to do an
effective Molly Hemingway just made a
fan fantastic point and Charlie this is
something that I think Republicans are
going to have to deal with right now the
leadership for the Republicans in the
Senate is pretty much working against
what the Republican electorate believes
on key issues China trade with China
some stuff on immigration maybe not the
Border issue specifically but and also
of course with this never ever ever
questioning what the Pentagon wants to
do that's a problem
yeah and not to mention a huge swath of
democrat voters who aren't down for this
stuff and if Republicans took a
principled stance in Washington on this
issue and other issues Not only would
they be doing the service of their own
voters but they would probably attract a
lot of democrat voters too well that was
Trump's uh Magic approach to all of us
actually bring those working-class
people together for America First our
border our country first and before we
can um you know what does it put your
mask on first before you try to help
help others if the plane's going down
Molly and Charlie great to see you both
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else